[Aplausos]
o povo maori da nova zelândia
aprendi desde muito pequeno a reconhecer
de onde ele veio
qual é a minha montanha qual é o meu rio
quais são os meus ancestrais para então
entender a sua identidade
e eu quando cheguei na nova zelândia
quatro anos atrás
achei aquilo incrível é preciso saber da
onde eu vim pra saber quem eu sou e eu
venho de uma família de mulheres fortes
minha bisavó atravessou o atlântico
grávida da minha avó
em 1900 como muitos imigrantes ela
deixou a sua terra as suas raízes em
busca de uma vida melhor
eu imagino a coragem que ela precisou
ter para largar tudo atravessar um
oceano e começar uma vida nova ainda
mais com uma vida na sua barriga e
aquela bebê que veio na sua barriga
minha avó foi outra mulher forte
quando meu avô morreu ela ficou sozinha
com seis filhos para criar
a única coisa que meu avô deixou para
ela foi um tear de bandeira e com aquele
tear
ela uniu a família os filhos aprenderam
a tc a trabalharem juntos ea cuidarem
uns dos outros os que eles fazem até
hoje
e aquela era uma vida muito dura naquela
época de muita escassez então os irmãos
trabalhavam 24 horas por dia tecendo
pequenas toalhas de barbeiro que o meu
pai meu tio viajavam brasil de praça em
praça vendendo aquelas falhas e assim
eles me ensinavam antes mesmo de eu
nascer de que eu podia construir o meu
trabalho eo meu destino
talvez essa história falha com alguns de
vocês que como eu vem de famílias
imigrantes porque migrantes são
empreendedores por natureza e quando eu
penso nas pessoas que vieram antes de
mim e que são parte de quem eu sou
eu percebo que cada uma delas me deu
ferramenta
cada uma me ensinou algo para eu
construir o meu caminho e vocês já
pararam para pensar sobre isso
o que vocês ganharam das pessoas que
vieram antes de vocês
minha mãe por exemplo me ensinou que era
possível uma mulher é independente numa
época onde não era como uma mulher morar
sozinha e trabalhar
ela me disse que a independência
financeira me traria liberdade
então vale a pena refletir sobre essas
coisas porque eles não ajuda nos
entender que não somos 105 anos depois
da minha bisavó foi a minha vez
eu atravessei o atlântico grávida de
cinco meses da minha segunda filha
quando eu morrer a bordo de um veleiro
difícil diferente da minha bisavó
eu voltava pra minha terra mas o que eu
não sabia naquela época é que aquela
experiência seria tão transformadora que
eu também atravessava o oceano rumo ao
desconhecido rumo a um novo modo de vida
e de trabalho
é verdade que eu sempre busquei o
desconhecido
o novo me atrai me fascina e fundei uma
agência de internet numa época de
internet só existia dentro da
universidade
ninguém entendia o que estava falando eu
entrava com as pessoas davam acesso de
presente ensinar a usar eu acreditava
tanto naquilo era tão apaixonada pelo
que eu fazia que eu atrair investidores
vêm de uma empresa para uma grande rede
de propaganda e depois à venda eu vivi
intensamente o mundo corporativo que
também era um mundo novo para mim eu
acabei cuidando de uma operação de 250
pessoas na américa latina em cinco
países viajava o tempo todo pra fora do
país e me sentia construído o futuro eu
era muito feliz mas é verdade que eu
trabalhava muito e eu não tinha tempo
para mais nada que não fosse o meu
trabalho
e foi assim que um dia eu tive nós
tivemos uma notícia que mudaria todas
nossas vidas
o meu marido teve um diagnóstico de um
câncer muito agressivo diziam que ele ia
viver pouco tempo de vida
então naquele momento nós fizemos várias
consultas e exames
se todos diziam a mesma coisa que ele
não teria muito tempo de vida
até que um dia muitos meses depois nós
descobrimos que o diagnóstico estava
errado que ele não tinha câncer mas
àquela hora com certeza mudança já tinha
acontecido dentro da gente
então nós largamos os nossos trabalhos e
fomos morar a bordo
nesse veleiro com a nossa filha de 1 ano
e 1 mês na época é foram seis anos
morando a bordo nós atravessamos dois
oceanos metade do planeta e eu aprendi a
ser mãe e professora das nossas filhas
de volta em terra firme
eu descobri que eu posso trabalhar onde
quer que eu tenha acesso à internet
hoje eu trabalho da nova zelândia com
pessoas e empresas vários lugares do
mundo incluindo o brasil e já que todo o
outro lado do mundo mesmo não faz a
menor diferença seu trabalho da minha
casa
seu trabalho do barco seu trabalho de
uma praça
eu preciso de um bom acesso à internet
de silêncio e de disciplina e nessas
horas a liberdade que eu conquistei fica
muito palpável e eu entendo porque eu
deixei a vida de trabalho no escritório
fechado das 9 da manhã às nove da noite
talvez alguns de vocês vivam também esse
jeito ele chama de novo digitais e um
movimento que cresce a cada dia mas que
também tem os seus desafios o trabalho
remoto traz isolamento
eu sou uma pessoa que gosta de estar
contra as pessoas no ambiente de trocas
de idéias me alimenta sinto falta
por isso eu me juntei esse ano um grupo
de empreendedores e comecei a trabalhar
um jeito diferente eu comecei a
trabalhar em rede e conectem com pessoas
que compartilham dos mesmos ideais
pessoas muito talentosas que escolheram
construir o seu trabalho e colaborar e
fazer coisas juntos mas não qualquer
projeto projetos que tenham significado
que tem um propósito
essa é uma reunião da rede da qual faço
parte hoje são 250 pessoas no mundo e
foram mais de 15 sapatos criados ao
longo de sete anos
em uma reunião lá e assim as pessoas que
estão na mesma cidade se reúnem juntas e
as outras se junta onde quer que estejam
o que eu posso dizer pra vocês depois de
ter experimentado tantos jeitos
diferentes de trabalhar é que não existe
um único caminho
mas o futuro do trabalho e agora é você
que cria somos nós que criamos
sem nenhuma ilusão não existe escolha
fácil ou perfeita tudo tem os dois lados
mas eu acho que quando nós conhecemos as
opções disponíveis e isso ajuda a
construir o caminho porque eu queria
compartilhar um pouquinho de alguns
aprendizados que eu tive ao longo de
todos esses anos construindo meu futuro
do trabalho e eu acho que uma das coisas
primeiros desafios de quem rompe com o
modelo tradicional de trabalho é como
conciliar liberdade com estabilidade
porque a estabilidade ela permite a
liberdade
eu só pude experimentar tanto porque eu
tinha uma situação financeira estável
mas eu não acho que você precisa vender
uma empresa como eu fiz pra dar esse
primeiro passo porque hoje é possível
experimentar
hoje você pode começar uma ideia nova
começar uma atividade paralela sem
precisar abrir mão do seu trabalho
você pode pegar um hobby algo que você
entenda muito começar um curso pela
internet
na verdade hoje existe um oceano de
possibilidades inclusive a possibilidade
de conversar na sua empresa e negociar
uma jornada mais flexível e mais móvel
eu detesto quando eu abro o jornal e eu
vejo falando de crise que agora todo
mundo tem que trabalhar o dobro e pra
ganhar metade porque é só assim que se
vive só mentira isso né eu não acredito
nisso
eu acho que sim existe espaço para
sentar lá e conversar fora do brasil já
isso já é bem comum
porque se a gente for pensar muitas
empresas não conseguem mais atrair os
melhores talentos
o mais ela não consegue atrair o melhor
da gente porque todo mundo que é uma
vida equilibrada vocês não querem
todo mundo quer então não tenho medo vão
lá e conversa
eu conheço pessoas que mudaram de país e
continuam trabalhando na mesma empresa
só que remotamente uma amiga fez uma
transição devagar ela conversou com os
donos da empresa com um ano de
antecedência dizendo que ela queria sair
porque ela queria ficar mais tempo com
os filhos que eles combinaram foi super
bacana eles combinaram que daquele tempo
além de treinar alguém para ficar no seu
lugar e um dia por semana ela não
precisava trabalhar para poder tocar os
seus projetos
no final de um ano ela tinha montado uma
pequena empresa de audiovisual
trabalhava como freelancer fazer os
projetos um jornal bem grande e tinha
fechado um contrato com uma empresa
grande para trabalhar um dia por semana
fazendo um projeto que tinha tudo a ver
com ela e que dá uma estabilidade
financeira que ela precisava então o que
eu percebo disso tudo é que combinar
vários modelos é faz toda a diferença
dificilmente um único tipo de trabalho
vai completar e eu sei por experiência
própria porque eu hoje eu sei que eu
preciso abrir espaço para as várias
sandra que tem dentro de mim
a empreendedora na executiva e para a
cidadã do mundo que adora viajar e
trabalhar onde quer que esteja
por que empreender pra mim me permite
desenvolver um projeto de longo prazo
que vai continuar e trabalhava numa
empresa significa ter recurso tem
estrutura para desenvolver uma coisa
realmente inovadora que tem impacto e
poder ter liberdade de trabalhar onde
quer que eu esteja me permite conhecer
novas culturas me permite aprender
coisas novas
me permite estar aqui hoje com a minha
família e ao mesmo tempo ter qualidade
de vida para as minhas filhas mas esse
um modelo que faz sentido pra mim é esse
modelo me ajudou a parar de viver para o
meu trabalho para parar de passar a
minha vida do trabalho e sim ajustar o
trabalho a minha vida mas cada um de
vocês vão ter motivações diferentes
vou seguir um outro caminho mas uma
coisa é certa hoje existe uma quantidade
enorme de possibilidades
e nós podemos combiná las de uma maneira
que que faça sentido e trabalhar de uma
maneira múltipla desse jeito exige novas
habilidades
a gente precisa ter flexibilidade
adaptabilidade para aprender a colaborar
mas pra mim uma das mais importantes é
ter ritmo porque quando tudo muda o
tempo todo
o ritmo é o que traz segurança
eu aprendi isso quando as minhas filhas
nasceram que uma coisa muito importante
para a criança pequena é hora de comer
é hora de dormir e brincar porque ela
sabe que todo dia que não vai acontecer
e só deixa segura e conosco é a mesma
coisa quando a gente vive uma realidade
que muda muito e eu acho que a gente
vive todos nós
quando muda muito de lugar a cada hora
trabalhando com pessoas diferentes em
projetos diferentes e estabelecer ritmo
é fundamental
eu por exemplo quando eu trabalho com
equipes em lugares diferentes
eu percebi a importância de ter
conversas regulares de poder saber o que
tá não tá fazendo de poder ter alguns
momentos pra parar refletir e gerar
aprendizado momento de mudar de rota e
isso tudo eu não tive dificuldade de
fazer remotamente
mas tem assuntos têm temas que você
precisa estar junto pessoalmente
então eu aprendi aproveitar melhor esses
momentos a organizar com bastante
cuidado e aproveitar os momentos que a
gente está junto para criar mesmo algo
concreto para criar as bases para que
depois a gente possa continuar
remotamente coisas do tipo qual o melhor
lugar para fazer esse encontro de
pessoas precisam está o que nós vamos
fazer é ter uma missão concreta o que
cada um vai comer porque a gente precisa
cuidar muito bem das pessoas para que
elas dêem o melhor de si e foi
trabalhando desse jeito remotamente
encontros e mercy vos que cuida da
operação de uma empresa de inovação no
brasil durante dois anos mesmo
trabalhando do outro lado no mundo e
vindo pra cá cada três meses e tem um
outro tipo de encontro que eu acho que
faz muita diferença
sam que são retiros na rede que eu faço
parte nós fazemos dois retidos por ano
a gente viaja para um lugar gostoso por
alguns dias com o tempo suficiente para
se conhecer para estabelecer as relações
que vão tornar o trabalho possível ea
colaboração possível para poder
aprofundar naqueles temas que a gente
nunca tem tempo no dia a dia e claro
para se divertir também que isso é
importante mas nesses momentos a gente
vivencia a cultura e os valores que nos
unem porque valores não são pra ficarem
no quadro preso na parede valores são
para ser vivenciados
então essas são coisas que fizeram muita
diferença para mim e por fim tem uma
última coisa que eu acho fundamental
para conseguir construir o trabalho que
tinha sintonia com a nossa vida que é o
autoconhecimento que é uma prática que
nos permite saber quem a gente realmente
é nos conectar com quem nós somos
isso pode ser feito com a ajuda de um
guru pode ser meditação pode ser uma
caminhada pode ser uma oração pode
acontecer se a gente precisar sair de
casa mas o fato é que quanto mais a
gente se conhece mas a gente descobre
quais são as nossas sombras quais são as
nossas luzes pois os nossos verdadeiros
talentos as nossas dificuldades o que
amamos o que não gostamos de jeito
nenhum o que queremos ou não queremos
nem sempre é um caminho florido
por vezes ele pode ser até esse período
mas vale muito a pena porque só quando a
gente sabe verdadeiramente quem a gente
é a gente tenha a liberdade ea coragem
de construir a vida que a gente quer
levando em conta o nosso propósito
sabendo porque a gente está fazendo
essas escolhas e eu queria perguntar pra
vocês
qual é o futuro que vocês gostariam de
criar pra vocês obrigada
[Aplausos]